You probably have gone to a pharmacy or doctor’s office
and slipped your arm into a device like this.
As the cuff squeezes and then gradually deflates,
it varies the external pressure on an artery in your arm.
A sensor inside the cuff measures blood volume
in the artery and the machine uses this data
to calculate your blood pressure.
Hypertension, or high blood pressure
is a major risk factor for heart disease
and strokes but it often goes unrecognized.
In developed countries 45% of people with hypertension
aren’t aware of it.
In developing countries it’s even higher--at 55%.
That’s why many want to increase access
to blood pressure screening tools,
but the standard cuff method isn’t very portable--
not that many people own them in the first place.
Now researchers have built a cuff-less device
to measure blood pressure that is convenient
and accessible.
This new device uses the same principle as
the conventional arm cuff, but instead of a cuff varying
the external pressure of the artery in your arm,
the user varies the external pressure
by steadily pressing their finger
against a special case attached to a smartphone.
The device is embedded with two sensors that measure
blood volume and applied pressure in the finger artery.
The case transmits the data via bluetooth to an app
on the smartphone, which computes the blood pressure
and provides a visual display to guide the user
and show results.
90% of participants got the hang of using it
after one or two tries.
the smartphone-based device was not quite as precise
as the arm cuff, but comparable to a finger cuff.
And it’s the first time this particular artery
in the fingertip has been shown to be an effective site
for blood pressure measurement.
Because smartphones already have nearly
all the hardware needed for this method--
you could potentially ditch the case altogether
and just add a thin-film force sensor
atop the phone’s existing optical sensor.
Another advantage of this system is that
many measurements can be made over time,
and then averaged to eliminate error from incorrect usage
or blood pressure variations due to stress,
physical activity, and other factors.
Since it relies on the user
to actively press on the double sensor,
the device cannot be used
to measure blood pressure at night,
which is clinically important.
The team still needs to test with a larger sample size
and they plan to add additional features
including an alert system
to warn users of high blood pressure
and securely transmit the results to caregivers.
After more prototypes and tests, researchers hope that
soon you’ll only have to reach into your pocket
for an easy and accurate way
to measure blood pressure.